- What is this thing about
consulting style presentations?
How are they different
from other types of business
presentations and why?
This is the topic that I'm
going to talk about today.
So welcome to another
coffee break or tea break,
as in my case today, on
my channel Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich.
And on my channel, I want to
help you to become successful
in the first years of your career.
So this week has been quite
special and unique for me.
So this is for sure.
And if you are a follower of
my Instagram, you know why.
Because indeed I became father this week.
My wife and I, we are
filled with thankfulness,
though the week has been quite exhaustive.
So if I look a bit tired
or you use some baby noises
in the background, now you
know why this is the case.
But let's get to the
meat of today's video.
And this is to learn about what's special,
what's unique about these
consulting style presentations
that I talked so often on my channel,
why they are the way they are,
and why they're different from
other presentation styles.
And indeed, if you want to learn more
about slide writing,
about creating presentations
in the style of leading consulting firms,
check out the playlist
that I have on this topic
or my channel.
I will link it somewhere above here.
And if you're really serious
to learn all the ins and outs
of how large consulting firms
like McKinsey, BCG, or Bain
create the slide presentations
I have a full end to end multi
hour course on that topic.
Check out the link in the
video description to it.
There are over 10,000 students
that took it the course
already with lots of reviews.
So have a look whether
this might be something
that might be of interest to you as well.
And today's video was actually inspired
by many of your comments.
So whenever I've created
one of these videos
that was about slide writing in the past,
many of you told me Heinrich,
aren't these slides far too full?
Why is there so much text on these pages?
Is this really a great way of
designing and layouting slides
if you actually intend to
present them in the end?
So this is what I want to address today.
Let's do that by looking
into different business
types of presentations.
And I like to distinguish
three different styles
of presentations.
For sure, you might be able to come up
with more different ones.
But these from my perspective
are probably the most
important, most relevant ones.
And the first style is the
style that I like to call
the Steve Jobs style.
These big keynote presentations,
as you often find them for
B2C product introductions,
where people are standing on a huge stage,
presenting to a large audience,
for instance about a new
product that is being launched
that is being introduced to the market.
So what is the thing
about these presentations?
Well, often there only a couple
of pictures on the slides,
maybe only a couple of words.
It's really for a large stage.
And what's really specific here
is that these presentations
are intended to be presented.
They absolutely require
that somebody stands
in front of the screen,
in front of the big canvas,
and give some explanations,
provide some soundtrack,
to the slides, explain
what is really shown here.
Or in other words,
if you would just send
around the slide deck,
without anybody explaining
it, probably most cases
for most people, it
would be quite difficult
to really understand all the details
about what this is
supposed to be all about.
So whenever I get comments of people
saying to me that all the
presentations that I use
they have too much text,
they're not clean, not minimal enough.
I'd assume that probably people
have this style in their mind.
Of course, the Steve Jobs
style has also become
quite well known, quite well studied.
So people assume that
this is also the style
of presentations that
businesses should be conducted.
But this is not the style
that I'm talking about
on my channel.
And indeed, this is also not
the way how consulting firms
at least in most cases, prepare
their slide presentations.
So let's contrast this
with a second use case of presentations.
I often like to think about
this as informal meetings.
So imagine yourself preparing a one-on-one
with your team lead,
or maybe an informal session
with some of your colleagues,
where you want to do some brainstorming,
and just bounce back some ideas,
prepare a couple of thoughts
as a discussion basis.
And here, of course,
the objective is just to
quickly create a short document
without you now needing
lots of time to create it,.
but enables you to have a
good and fruitful discussion
with your team.
It's an important characteristic
of this style of business presentations
is that there's no need
to reuse these slides.
These slides are really
just for usually one or two interactions
where you discuss topics.
There's no need to have this really ready
for a larger audience and
additional one comment
that often people say is,
Heinrich, do you really need
to invest that much time
into every single
presentation that you do?
Do you always need to create presentations
in the style that meet
these really high standards
of slight writing,
these high standards of presentations,
how large consulting
firms like McKinsey, BCG
or Bain do it?
And here my answer would
be well, no, of course not.
Of course this style is absolutely valid
if you just quickly want to
bounce back a couple of ideas,
just have a meeting and
interaction with your team.
Don't waste too much
time on perfect layout,
on perfect communication on the slides.
Keep it short, keep it simple.
Make adjustments in the
way that enables you
to have this discussion
that you do want to have.
So if this is clear to you,
then you might ask yourself,
then what is this style?
What is this consulting style
of creating presentations?
How does this now differ
from the other ones?
And indeed these presentations
are often more formal ones.
You create them for more formal audiences,
for senior management, or
board-level members of a company.
These are presentations that you create
to report on the progress of your project.
And indeed, what's probably
also very interesting
is that these presentations are often
not even presented.
So often in these meetings,
they're not even projected
to a wall, to a screen.
But people just get a
handout of the document
that then they have in front of you.
And indeed what also frequently happens
is that at least then after the meeting,
these presentations are being
sent around the organization.
People just forward them to other people.
And then other read these documents.
We're not sitting in the original meeting
where maybe the document
was initially presented.
And indeed, I very well
remember an instance,
I was working for a company,
and at this company a couple of years ago,
like two or three years ago,
BCG, Boston Consulting Group,
made a project with them.
And as a final reside of this project,
there was now a document
that Boston Consulting Group created.
This was also in the style
of a big PowerPoint presentation.
And up to this day,
this document is still being referenced
and sent around, and called
just the BCG Document.
And from this anecdote alone,
there are some really important learnings.
So the first is that
these documents, again,
are not necessarily
intended to be presented.
It's important that people can understand
every message of these documents,
if they just read it for themselves.
So every single slide,
every single page in such a document,
needs to be self-explanatory,
needs to speak for itself.
And this of course requires
a higher level of detail,
often a higher level of
text, more text on the slides
in order for these presentations
to stand for themselves.
Next is the fact that your
reputation as a consulting firm
but also if you work
in-house as a project lead
for a big corporate,
your reputation as the one
that creates these documents
is very much linked
to the quality of this document, right?
So because these documents can
have a very high shelf life,
if there are any errors in
there, any inconsistencies,
any imprecise statements, it will be known
that this was the document
created by BCG or by you.
And years later, potentially
people still think about this
look at this and we'll
have this in their mind.
Another important consideration
is that of course,
the composition of
teams changes over time.
So if a document is looked
at maybe a year from now,
in most cases, the consulting
firm the created that
will not be at the company anymore.
Or maybe also the employees
that work together
with the consultants to
create this document,
maybe they move to a new job,
to a new employer, to a new company.
So there might not even be
somebody who can be asked
what was done at the time,
what really happened,
what numbers exactly to look at?
And again, this is just one more reason
why it's so important to
really create these documents
at the high standards
that I try to teach you
your honor videos on this channel,
and also in my course.
Again, if you do want
to check the full course
that I have on this topic,
check out the link in
the video description.
So I do hope that this video
cleared up some confusion
on when exactly this style
of creating presentations
is to be used, and when
also this is not necessary,
not required to put that much effort
into these presentations,
and also especially why
it is not to be confused
with the Steve Jobs style, keynote style,
of creating presentations,
but why coinciding firms
usually create the presentations
and a bit of a different style,
and why this of course
is not only relevant
and important for consulting
firms, but for you as well,
if you work in corporate and
banking one any other career
where you are in a position
to frequently create presentations
for C-level, senior
management type of audiences
that you are talking to.
So if you have any questions about that,
please leave me a comment
in the comment section.
You know, that I do my very best
to answer every single
comment that you write.
And yes, your comments also help me
with the YouTube algorithm.
Indeed, if you took any value
out of this video at all
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm,
you know the drill.
And also subscribe to my channel
to stay up to date and all my content.
And you can also follow
me on my Instagram.
The handle is firmlearning.
I also have a mailing list, and
other educational offerings.
Just check out the video description
for more details on that.
And now I just also want to
take a moment to say thank you
to all the members of Firm Learning.
You're really helping me a lot.
Thanks so much.
And if you want to
become a member as well,
just hit the join button
next to the subscribe button
to learn about all the perks
that you would be getting
if you join Firm Learning as a member.
Thanks so much.
Good weekend to all of you.
I release new videos
every single Saturday.
So see you again next
Saturday, all the best to you.
Heinrich here from Firm Learning.
Cheers.